in order to manage AI fatigue
another area where you can look at is your cognitive load
yes
remember when you're working or deploying any application to a server
the load determines the space that you need
sometimes when you have too much traffic
that is way beyond the load or the capacity of what the site can have
that site will break down
same goes with me human
if you don't understand the committive load that is attached to you
you find yourself circling around writing prompt again and again
and at the end of the day
you're not making progress
so here are some of the question you should ask
first is am I thinking or just reviewing the output
or am I prompting repeatedly without any progress
or am I mentally tired after short session
all these questions are very
very important when you're working with artificial intelligence
because you will soon realize that before you know it
you're giving prompt you're writing code
you're burning AI token but at the end of the day just lesser results
so if you want to fix this
you need to understand when that recursion or that loop is happening
so that you can break out of it
you can take some break or try some other approach
so that you can quickly have the result
that you're looking at getting